Please, welcome George Oliphant!
(audience cheering)
Yes!
Welcome.
Thank you.
Oh, George, George,
my beating heart that loves love.
I love you.
You're such a kind, good human being.
Thank you very much.
It's so great to be here,
and I've always been a fan of yours and Ross',
and just to be here-
Oh, thank you.
With both of you, awesome.
I mean, you're just such a good person,
and you take such good care of people.
Well, that's what it's all about.
We gotta take care of each other, right?
And on "George to the Rescue," we say it takes a village,
and the communities coming together
to help those who need it the most.
Yeah.
A long time ago, my dad said, just be yourself,
and my mom, she concurred.
And I was like, it's easier to be me
than to try to be somebody else, so.
That part.
That part, and you, the way you do things and what you do,
you are the perfect person to help with
this Design Drew Over.
So Laura is a nurse and a mom from Bohemia, New York.
She wrote into us for a little help with DIY.
Take a look at this.
(upbeat music)
Hi, my name is Laura Dunac-Beigay.
I'm 40 years old, and I live here in Bohemia, New York.
I've been married to my husband for about 13 years,
and we have two great kids together.
We moved into our home about five or six years ago,
and like any other homeowner,
you have great dreams and aspirations
of all the work you can get done, right?
So we started off with the bathroom,
probably not the best idea.
One of the towel racks fell,
and we tried to spackle it ourselves.
I have to say, I am a nurse.
This is not in my wheelhouse, not in my repertoire at all.
It's just such an eyesore.
Drew, can you please help me with this Drew Over?
Oh my god, right?
Well, I am so excited and honored that you asked me,
and I would do exactly what I'm doing now,
which is hand the mic over to George,
and you could teach us how to do this.
That may not be in her wheelhouse,
but it is definitely in my wheelhouse,
and I'm happy to show you and the audience at home
so that everyone can fix the holes
that they put in their walls.
Okay, I have a hole in my new house.
Like, there was, I guess, supposed to be a door stopper,
and I pushed the door and the knob went, boom,
went like that.
Yeah.
So I'm looking at it like, what do I do?
All right, well, hey, this is the perfect fix right here.
One of the big problems that people do,
a lot of times people put a patch over it.
What you wanna do is what we have here is a backer plate,
and that actually, we've already put 'em in both here,
but what it is is just this plate right here.
How'd you get it in?
You slide it in, you roll it up like this,
so it rolls.
Okay.
You pull off the adhesive right here,
and then you slide it in.
And then this little part you were asking me about,
that pulls it taut against the inside of the wall.
So now, right now, so you're good.
Now, it's already there, so you guys are good to go.
You sort of like, fold it like a taco.
Yeah, you put this right back
Put it inside, let it expand, and then pull it,
and the tabs will make the tape go on the other side.
Yeah, so it's like that double sided tape.
So it's really a strong adhesive,
so it's gonna stick to the inside of your wall,
and that way, when you're putting the compound on here,
it doesn't just all fall into the cavity of the wall
between the studs.
Cavity, of course.
That's what it's called, the cavity.
I love the word cavity.
Of course.
Yeah, this is making a lot of sense.
Right?
Like, my mind would never be able to do this.
No, you'd be filling the hole, the cavity.
Right, you'd fill the cavity,
and you'd fill the whole wall.
You know what I would do?
I would just put a painting right here.
Yeah.
Just to like, cover it.
That's what I would do.
That was my move in college.
Okay.
I did a lot of that.
So once you get the folded taco
with the double-sided tape,
and you secure in place, AKA the backer-
Yep.
Now what?
Now you put this little ribbon
right back in that little hole there.
Okay.
And now it is time to fill the hole.
Oh fun, okay.
All right.
So if you had small hole,
you could use something like this,
which is nice because it's got the compound in it,
you have your little knife,
and you have your sandpaper at the end.
But since this is a bigger hole-
Yes, let's go hardcore.
Look at that.
You're already on it.
You really wanna overfill the hole at first.
And you wanna start from the middle,
and you work your way out.
I'm very into how much this looks like frosting
or cream cheese or something, right?
Whipped cream cheese,
that's what I always say.
Yeah.
It looks like a whipped cream cheese.
It is.
It's like a whipped filling.
All right, yep.
So start filling and work your way to the edges.
Oh, okay.
Yep.
Okay. All right.
Nice, yep.
Good.
Oh God.
You're doing great.
Thank you.
This is very satisfying.
I like this, George.
Yes.
You got it.
And just, yeah, work it out to each edge.
So you got it, and you just wanna overfill it
not too much, but yes.
Perfect.
Drew, you can come to "George to the Rescue anytime."
(Drew squealing)
You always have a good time with me.
Well, thanks a lot, George.
No, no, no, you're welcome too.
You're welcome, Ross.
I'm just-
Alright, so yeah.
Good, good.
I mean, I feel like,
well, I feel like my hole is a lot bigger than Drew's.
It's taking a lot.
(all laughing)
Great, all right.
So now, okay, now, yes.
And you work, again, like I said,
you wanna work from the middle of the whole out
towards the edges.
Okay.
Ross, I'm done.
You are basically done, yeah.
And now, I mean, you're gonna, you know,
you have a couple spots, but-
I was gonna say.
Once it's all in-
See, that's what happened,
And you smooth
it out a little bit.
I got cocky.
Okay, good, good.
Now we let it dry.
Oh, Drew.
And we don't wanna overwork the hole.
(Drew laughing)
All right, is that good, George?
Just like, can I-
That's pretty good.
Yeah, no, that's, yeah.
Just yes, no, now it's good.
Now it's good.
Do I stop now?
You can stop now.
Okay, I'm stopping.
I'm stopping.
And don't worry about like, you know,
the little imperfections-
The lines.
Because it's gonna dry.
And then you can like-
Then we're gonna sand it.
Okay.
(upbeat music)